hey what's up Evan this is this is the
man this is the man Samari Robinson
welcome aboard man hey I'm happy to be a
part of this interview man
so Samari is an actor while you're doing
YouTube stuff I know your Instagram
influencer for sure yeah I'm doing
Instagram for now but I'm eventually
gonna get on YouTube got a lot of comedy
stuff some funny stuff I was watching
your video this morning about the teens
you got the mom he's like you're the mom
and then you're the Sonny the mom again
it's good yeah and you're like what do
you add on Instagram like 100 hundred
something you're over a hundred thousand
on Instagram uh-huh support guys you've
been following my stuff for a little bit
oh yeah what's your favorite video on
the channel I gotta say my favorite
video is its a mix between the Tom
Bilyeu series like when we look at his
quotes okay and then a mix of
what's-his-name Les Brown unless all
less brown man I love Johnny Wes Brown
is my hero oh my gosh especially in the
morning I wake up so guys here's kind of
my schedule I want to reveal to you guys
this is it this is it the secrets are
coming out every day I wake up at 5:00
a.m. and as soon as I wake up I listen
to this guy right here who I'm
interviewing with this man right here
and then I go straight to the gym and
then I go and then I go right back home
when I start my day but it's like it's
like this every single day and so it's
like a real honor to be interviewing
with you right now boy mm-hmm so yeah
that's that's kind of how I start every
day and honestly it's the best way to
start every day I have so much energy I
am full of positivity and honestly I
feel like it kind of matures me in a way
to you know waking up early you know
being the first one in my house to open
their eyes and then just have starting
my day early like it's really helpful
would you consider yourself an
entrepreneur and what you're doing okay
you know I see actors as entrepreneurs
you got to get up and and the rejection
is ridiculous oh and a daily on a daily
and so talk
me about the importance of the of the
Morningstar how you stay like getting up
every day getting rejected keep going
every day get rejected and like you
finally hopefully make a hit so a lot of
entrepreneurs are certain the business
it's the same thing but but they don't
they don't get up and keep going like
they're they're super inconsistent they
start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop and so how do you when
you're getting pummeled every day and
everybody's saying no man you're not
what we want
or you're in Atlanta or whatever the
reason is like how do you keep on that
motivation train well guys I gotta tell
you the truth so I am rejected 24/7 like
every day I am told no no no no no you
can't D on this you can't do that blah
blah blah how I keep going is I just
blot it out like I don't even take it
personal I don't think much about it
because at the end of the day I know
that I'm gonna make it I know that I'm
going to make it and it's funny because
next month in LA I'm shooting a show an
awesome congrats man but like like how
how do you know you're gonna make it
because so many people like they don't
know and then they'll keep doing it
well I know I'm gonna make it because
I'm taking actions towards it and I know
that my habits and my faith in myself is
gonna lead me to it I just believe in
myself 100% and nobody can change that
and I gotta say that's my advice like
believe in yourself trust yourself
because honestly you know I know I've
been put on this world to do great
things and I just make sure I execute on
it and I just keep going like there's
not anybody in the world I could stop me
for the people who want to be an actor
or now want to be an entrepreneur and
they most of the time believe themselves
but then they have days where they don't
like how do you rescue yourself so that
you stay consistent I do have those days
I do you know there's time so I thought
it was impossible like for example of
making videos getting a hundred thousand
followers guys I didn't even think I'd
get fifty thousand followers
I'm like I'm being dead serious I've
achieved almost every actually I've
achieved every one of my goals this year
literally every single goal
and at one point I remember when I first
started like a few months like I think
maybe February or March I thought it was
impossible I didn't think I could even
go this far guys
and regardless I just kept pushing
I felt like believing that it was
impossible it became my duty to continue
going and so that's what I did
and I started posting every single day
days or I couldn't post you know their
word date guys there were days where I
could not post like I like crazy things
are happening like I'd had three
auditions in one day or some sort of
family issue but I just kept doing it
and I just kept remaining disciplined
and I stuck to my schedule and that's
why waking up at 5 a.m. is really
helpful it's so crazy what a little bit
of discipline and perseverance can do
for you what was the most painful
rejection that you got Oh pick me the
picture bring me back to the moment
summary bring me back to the moment dude
this is it
what to feel the hurt all right so guys
there was this one time I was
auditioning for Empire and I did so bad
I was preparing for like five days for
this role like I was I was going over my
speed breaking it down going over rap
songs and I remember when I came into
the room I just completely blanked out
like just completely blanked out like
all that hard work I put in just
completely left left the window and I
was just stuck there like a deer in
headlights
it was horrible but I remember I really
wanted the role I did that on the
audition and no I didn't book it but I
gotta say that was my most painful
experience as far as rejection there
were other times too
when I was auditioning for Nickelodeon
shows and I felt like I had it I'd get
called accidents everyone just seemed
like they were loving me and I wouldn't
get it there were some really hard times
there were times again what I thought it
was impossible and it's just all about
pushing through those times it becomes
your duty during those days guys it's
just keep yeah
keep pushing that's kind of been my
motto when it becomes really hard then
just work even harder I was watching a
the Kate Winslet video that we did on my
channel and that the opening clip is how
her drama teacher in school told her
yeah you might get some parts as the fat
girl
but I don't really have a dream of going
and being an actress because you're not
gonna make it right so it's like it's
crazy you hear the stories of rejections
just like I think being an actor is the
highest rejection feel to be in period
oh yeah did you have experiences like
before being an actor to help you that
helped you build the thick skin to be
able to handle this I would say football
kind of helped me a little bit okay
I'd say football kind of toughened me up
okay football I remember what I started
out I was third string I was not in the
games at all I wasn't doing nothing and
I was always playing with kids that were
older than me so I had like no shot of
ever beating them at anything but I just
kept playing and I just kept going to
practices and I kept training and I kept
playing you know talking to old
teammates and I just kept improving and
eventually I ended up starting over
eleven kids so you know I got to say
football helped me with pressure
variance did it helped me over direct
rejection yes because I was always never
never playing for a while but it changed
like I said with consistency and hard
work everything changed and so I feel
like that's the same thing with acting
look if I never booked another role
again I will make my own show I will
write my own scripts I want to be a
director and a writer and a producer too
and of course I'm doing social media
guys I'm making videos you already doing
it man you already directing your d
scripting absolutely nothing in the
world is gonna stop me even if no one
books me I'm still gonna make it I love
a man like the ROC certain football -
mm-hmm yeah you got cut there he went
the wrestling you skip the wrestling
step man you skip the wrestling step
he's going right to acting I'll be a WWE
in three summers wise oh you're going
the other way you're going you're going
acting into wrestling later I got it who
are your idols who do you look up to
that's a really good question you know I
bounced around I look at everybody but I
gotta say Will Smith is really awesome I
love Will Smith I love him
the rock is a really good story he got
cut from the NFL oh no from the CFL bout
yeah yeah main goal and everything guys
yeah he got cut from his entire life
dream was ruined and now that was the
best thing that could ever happen to him
cuz he's a rock you know and then I'm
split between a few other people too but
I gotta say you know those two guys are
really inspirational
um I like listening to Tom Tom Bill you
he's really awesome in the morning Les
Brown les you know he's awesome I mean I
listen to more people but I gotta say
guys having positivity garyvee you know
I was on Gary Vee show early in July
yeah I was nice I love Gary Vee I listen
to them all the time you know it's
really good to have positivity in your
ears 24/7 especially with what I do you
know making videos is not easy guys
I get all sorts of hate all the time so
you know I just I keep going man you
know hard work pays off and I gotta say
it's really nice having positivity in
your ears well I love the rock yes he
got cut from the cfl and then he said he
wanted to be a wrestler and his dad said
like don't go be a wrestler uh-huh yeah
and then and then he still went went to
be a wrestler and he was barely making
it as a wrestler and then he had an idea
of going to Vince McMahon who was in
charge of the WWF at the time the WWE
and said like I just want to give a
speech at the end of my match and let me
give a speech and he said okay okay cuz
everything's scripted and programmed out
like there was no room for his speech
but he said I wanna can I just have a
minute to give a speech and he get up
when he did his thing and that that
became the start of the rock that people
loved him for that he was a fringe
wrestler and then after that speech he
took off and so's like betting on
yourself right like not being afraid to
say hey like I have an idea even though
it's not the square
how about we try this can you can you
let me do this one thing for 60 seconds
and see how it works right a lot of
people too afraid to do that mm-hmm you
got to get at your comforts on your I G
bio and your videos all talk about
making people laugh oh yeah there's a
lot of ways to be an actor a lot of
different things you can cover but why
why laughs like why is that so important
to you why is that what you're building
your finger in okay guys so I was
honestly always the class clown and it's
like all the time it doesn't even matter
like I wouldn't even say a joke and
somehow I just make someone laugh like I
don't know I I guess I guess I'm one of
those type of people so why not make
some videos plus it's really fun to I
just make videos I put it online people
watch them and laugh I gotta say Samari
squad you guys are awesome you guys have
helped me some through some really tough
times so I just love making people laugh
I love to create positivity I love to
just see people smile and just hopefully
bring like a like a minute of joy
happiness of someone's day you know what
I mean but where does that come from why
is that so important to you
well I mean I've always thought of it
like like this like I've always had hard
times you know like as far as acting I'm
constantly getting rejection so you got
to look at things and you got to see the
the comedic value in it you know you got
it you got to see the positivity in
things and I feel like laughs there
helps you through that especially with
that I do and how many knows I get you
know you got a laugh you gotta find
something to laugh at when are you
moving out to LA I'm moving up LA in two
weeks Bella's nice man talk to me about
the importance like LA you're going yes
that's where the jobs are for your field
but talk to me about the importance of
creating an environment or being an
environment for someone who's bounced
around a lot like a lot of people are
afraid to to move to go somewhere else
like if their currents if they're in
some tiny city and it doesn't support
them and all their friends and family
are negative saying you can't do it how
do you get the courage you just say you
know what like I'm gonna move I'm gonna
go to LA I'm gonna I'm gonna go ed land
at this thing I'm gonna like how do you
get that courage but how important is it
well it's funny guys cuz when I moved to
LA I'm moving completely on my own
like I'm not moving with any family like
it's it's on my own so that's gonna be
like a first time for me I like the fact
that moving or going to new places you
know it typically helps me think like
hmm going to a new place like my mind my
mind completely resets and I'm like I'm
like starting from scratch and I really
like that and Los Angeles of all places
it's really competitive you know
everybody's trying to do it idea and
it's tons of a cube and there's tons of
people make a funny video so you know
and I go out there it's gonna be awesome
because it's like I have a whole bunch
of people like me out there so it's
gonna force me to grow and to learn you
know and I think that environment will
help me and I think traveling always
reap that fun line and so it's it's
gonna be perfect when I go out there you
were born and raised in Florida mm-hmm
and then you first went out to LA like
did you say I'm gonna move to LA and be
here for two years or you just went for
a weekend to check it out what what was
a journey well we originally went to LA
and I said I'm gonna be here for three
months
just to see what it's like okay I ended
up liking it a lot to say the least so I
stayed there for like two years and a
little more than three months and I
really enjoyed it so we went back to it
look we went to Atlanta because it's
cheaper up here and you want to make
sure that when I go to out like this you
know I shouldn't be bringing my whole
family outside legs between me cuz it's
my career and my mom decided to bring me
my little brother my dad we all go as a
family we decided to go to LA to help me
achieve my career my dreams and career
that was really time for them and I'm
really grateful for that
they went to LA to help you with your
career yep damn dude I mean you have
like the greatest family of all time
it's great what do you tell people
watching who are saying man he's just
lucky he got great parents you know my
family would never do that for me well
what kind of advice you tell them cuz
they still need to work hard they seem
to go chase it uh-huh absolutely I just
have to say you know I'm really grateful
that I had the family that I did but yes
if I didn't have them I would still be
doing what I was doing you know my
mom they've didn't start my Instagram
for me you know no one told me to do
what I did you know I totally did it on
my own now my parents helped me out with
the move out there yeah
but I'm 18 now and I'm trying to make a
little bit of money so I'm going out
there on my own anyways you know so I
would just have to say for you guys who
may not your family may not support you
to announce to them you know whether
you're getting positivity or negativity
- now - all of it just focus on you have
that tunnel disk and focus on their
goals and so if you want to be in LA and
be an actor go for it you know if you
don't have family to support you get a
job outfit something you know but that's
my advice you know I was just love to
have my family you know at the time and
that he really helped me out
but regardless I still would have done
how we found away what are you most
afraid of when you move out I'm most
afraid of an earthquake crushed in our
building no but I think you know there's
a lot of things I don't really scary
like it's my first time like moving out
I'm gonna be in the other side of the
continent living on my own you know so
you know there's a lot of things that
can go wrong but I it doesn't matter you
know it's all about taking risks and
she's going through it's going through
the obstacles you know so I could I
could theoretically you know not have
enough money to pay for my place I could
theoretically get robbed out there you
know a bunch of things should happen
guys I don't care I'm gonna find a way
to win regardless of those things if you
happen so you know I'm just ready I'm
ready to go to war I love a man I love I
love your positivity I love your energy
I'm cheering for you like I can't wait
to have you back on and we're doing like
top 10 volume 18 of Samarra Robinson
making the legendary career happen
I mean we're gonna put this on my
YouTube channel so for the people who
may not know you in my audience one like
where can they find you under how can
they follow your journey in this in this
trip yeah you guys can find me on
instagram so Mari underscore Robinson my
goal right now is I gotta be a million
followers I'm gonna be doing a whole
bunch of stuff guys and I'm just ready
to make some amazing content just make
you laugh you're chasing down the me
Liam on Instagram yep yep love it dude
you guys win coming
yeah baby let's see it I want to see it
cool man appreciate the time final
message like people they have one thing
to remember Samara Robinson by what is
it hard work pays off oh it's been a
grind this year man it's been a grind I
didn't even think I'd build this far and
I'm here the hard work pays off guys
cool man appreciate it well thanks for
the time
good luck on the move man we're all
cheering for you and I can't wait to
watch your first movie in theaters let
me know when it says hey I just wanna
let you know man I love your stuff man
like I really do you're an amazing guy
like I think I think God sent you here
to just help people like legit you're an
amazing dude I love your content and you
helped me so much so much and so I just
got to thank you for that you [ __ ] a man
appreciate it when I pick million
followers and I'm a million because of
my visited and I'm a star and acting I
gotta say you're invited to my premieres
brother listen I want to be into the
first premiere even when you even if
you're not there man I guarantee it you
are invited to my premieres man you've
helped me so much I'm pumped man and
I'll see you in LA soon all right Thank
You Man take if you're watching and
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new 250 for confidence series
where every day
to the next 254 days for free I will
send you a 30-second 5-minute video in
the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description below if you want to be
more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you loved you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon if
you want to learn how to make it as an
actor check out the video there right
next to me and there's lots of tips I
think will help you continue to believe
and I'll see you there
everybody told me not to be an actor to
this day I say that to people who come
up to me and say I'm thinking of going
into acting what do you think I say
absolutely not it's a terrible idea
don't do it